bien mes chers mes chers collègues
au terme de quatre auditions plénières
consacrées à la ressource en eau je
formule le veut que les échanges et
permis à chacun d'entre vous d'être
comme un poisson dans l'eau quand il
s'agit d'un visager les enjeux hydriques
notre cycle au long cours engager ces
dernières semaines à démontrer il
n'était pas exagéré de considérer l'eau
dans tous ces aspects comme l'un des
défis du 21e siècle la sécheresse
inédite de l'été dernier a mis en
évidence la fragilité les fragilités
hydriques des territoires et le manque
de robustesse de certains réseaux de
distribution d'eau
cette crise a heureusement pu être
surmontée grâce à l'implication des
acteurs de l'eau de l'état des élus
locaux mais nous devons y voir un
indicateur de la fin de l'abondance
aquatique dans notre pays
la raréfaction de la ressource en eau
ouvrent une nouvelle ère qui nous impose
de changer de
paradigme sur la gestion de l'eau nous
devons dès à présent sans plus attendre
préparer le futur hydrique de la France
à l'aide de nouveaux instruments
instruments réglementaires instrument
administratif et surtout financier et en
s'implant en simplifiant ce qui est
inutilement complexe les conflits
d'usage ne sont plus l'apanage des pays
au climat des articles où semi aride la
les séchage c'est Steven récurrentes
sont la preuve que l'eau peut devenir
une source de conflit à travers les
tensions hydriques entre les différents
usages aussi vitaux les uns que les
autres notre souveraineté alimentaire
résilience et autonomie de notre mix
énergétique à travers la production
d'hydroélectricité et le refroidissement
des centrales nucléaires
le développement du fret fluvial que la
Commission appelle de ses vœux pour
favoriser le report vers des modes de
transport moins intenses en carbone ou
le nécessaire maintien de la
biodiversité aquatique et des trames
bleues pour ne citer que les usages les
plus intuitifs de l'eau face à cette
crise révélatrice des fragilités
hydriques de nos territoires une prise
de conscience commence à s'opérer les
acteurs de l'eau publique et privés ils
ont vu une mise en garde de douloureuse
mais salutaire dans la mesure où elle
contribue à faire figurer à l'agenda
politique des enjeux de résilience
hydrique
au niveau national mais également à
l'échelle locale après les assises de
l'eau le varen agricole de l'eau elle
adaptation au changement climatique et
la séquence de planification écologique
consacrée à l'eau les constats sont
clairs il n'est plus envisagé ni
envisageable de continuer comme avant la
sobriété devient indispensable la
réutilisation doit être encouragée il
faut organiser le partage de l'eau de
façon claire et lisible en somme la
politique de gestion de l'eau doit
gagner en agilité et en adaptativité
mais prise de conscience ne suffit pas
connaissance si nous entrevoyons les
enjeux de la raréfaction de la ressource
en eau
il ne nous apparaissent pas encore clair
comme de l'eau de roche la question
mérite en effet d'être exploré sous
l'angle des défis concrets et des
incidences sur les pratiques et les
usages
d'ailleurs j'étais bloqué avec un camion
quelqu'un qui arrosé les trottoirs à
Paris je trouve ça
superbement étonnant enfin bon c'est
assez
donc il va peut-être falloir changer
quand même les
usages et les pratiques d'ailleurs la
consommation avait envisagé de lancer
une mission d'information au format
Flash consacré aux petits cycle de l'eau
avec pour point d'attention l'État et la
performance des réseaux ainsi que la
qualité de traitement des eaux usées
avant le rejet dans le milieu naturel
entre temps le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains souhaitaient
exercer son droit de tirage sur ce thème
central est demandé la création d'une
mission d'information consacrée à la
gestion durable de l'eau l'urgence
d'agir pour nos usages nos territoires
et notre environnement qui sera présidé
ce dont je me félicite puisqu'il s'agit
des membres de la commission par notre
collèguerémy pintro et dont le
rapporteur sera et ne sera pas et Hervé
gilet que je salue il m'a donc apparu
opportun de laisser cette mission menée
un bien ses travaux et d'attendre les
conclusions et les recommandations
qu'elle verseront débat public afin de
ne pas multiplier les instances
travaillant sur des sujets similaires
conformément aux recommandations du
groupe de travail sur la modernisation
de nos méthodes de travail présidées par
notre collègue Pascal gr
à l'issue des travaux qui
vont s'engager il ne sera à loisible aux
besoins d'approfondir le sujet si la
mission commune d'information fait le
choix de ne pas l'aborder mais revenons
à l'objet de notre table ronde
d'aujourd'hui pour aborder ces questions
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
d'accueillir Monsieur Frédéric vaux
délégué interministe en charge du suivi
des conclusions du varen agricole de
l'eau et de l'adaptation du changement
climatique monsieur
Pellegrini président de la Fédération
Française professionnelle des
entreprises de l'eau
monsieur oui c'est vous mais il manque
votre collègue Monsieur Bruno chargé
directeur des relations
institutionnelles régulations et
coordination de l'eau EDF hydro et il
manque vague zen Andrea sien directeur
de l'unité des hydro-systèmes quand il
entend anthropisé j'invite chaque
intervenant en cours de son propos
militaire de liminaire pas militaire de
3 minutes maximum afin de laisser du
temps aux échanges à présenter les défis
concrets que pose la raréfaction de la
ressource hydrique au regard de sa
position institutionnelle ou
scientifique grâce à la diversité des
intervenants les angles d'approche
concernant les enjeux agricoles et la
souveraineté alimentaire les questions
d'Orient résoudre les que devront
résoudre les gestionnaires du petit
cycle de l'eau les implications
concrètes de la raréfaction et de la
saisonnalité plus marquée de la
ressource pour la production
d'électricité et enfin les défis tels
qu'entrevue par un scientifique
spécialiste de la modélisation
mathématique des barres Saint-Vincent
grâce à laquelle peut-être produite des
connaissances en matière de prévision
des crues des tiages d'évaluation des
impacts du changement climatique des
sols et du climat c'est à dire la
richesse des points de vue
je vous aide maintenant la parole place
aux échanges qui veut commencer parmi
les trois intervenants
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs je voudrais
aborder rapidement trois points pour
rester dans le temps imparti d'abord un
rappel très rapide de ma mission comme
délégué interministériel pour le varen
agricole de l'eau et d'adaptation au
changement climatique
ensuite peut-être mais vous avez dû en
débattre j'imagine déjà qu'est-ce qu'on
entend par réfraction de la ressource
raréfaction de la ressource en eau et
puis en troisième point sur les grandes
réponses qui sont apportées par le varen
donc tout d'abord par rapport à ma
mission je ne suis pas un spécialiste ni
scientifique ni technique de l'eau j'en
suis tout au plus un praticien puisque
j'ai eu assez à gérer des épisodes de
sécheresse avec des conséquences très
différentes à Mayotte puis comme préfet
de la Corrèze ma mission c'est la mise
en œuvre du varen qui est centré sur
de l'eau en agriculture
il faut juste rappeler que
l'agriculture représente 9% des 32
milliards de mètres cubes de prélèvement
mais 45% des 5 milliards de mètres cubes
de consommation de l'eau et donc avant
le secteur énergétique ou l'eau potable
quand on quand on part raréfaction de la
ressource en eau pour cela je
souhaiterais me référer à la synthèse
qui a été faite par
la Délégation à la prospective du Sénat
à la fin du du mois de novembre qui nous
dit la France hexagonale se trouve en
bordure de la zone
d'arridification comme on dit la plus
géométrie sera plus marquée par la
saisonnalité
la moitié sud de la France connaîtra un
climat plus sec et nous aurons une
baisse des débits des cours d'eau ceci
résulte de deux choses des études du
GIEC et les études explorent 2070 qui
avait été conduite il y a une dizaine
d'années et qui dans le cadre du varen
est en cours d'actualisation c'est ce
qu'on appelle explore 2
la conséquence première pour
l'agriculture c'est que moins d'eau sera
et est disponible au moment du plus
grand besoin des cultures c'est à dire
fin du printemps et première partie de
l'été la deuxième conséquence à en tirer
c'est de faire évoluer comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le Président notre gestion
de de l'eau
alors très rapidement les réponses
apportées par le varen le varen
se présente sous la forme de trois axes
stratégiques et 24 mesures les trois
axes sont d'une part protection de
l'agriculture le sujet essentiel c'est
la l'assurance récolte qui est qui a été
adopté qui encourt de déploiement
et qui n'est pas dans le périmètre de
compétences de la délégation le deuxième
volet du varen c'est l'adaptation de
l'agriculture au changement climatique
et que faisons-nous à ce titre d'abord
il y a toute une série de plans
d'adaptation qui sont conduits par les
différentes filières agricoles avec un
appui de France agrimaire comment on
évolue face au changement climatique
nous prolongeons ces travaux par le
déclenchement d'une mission du Conseil
Général de l'agriculture d'alimentation
et des espaces ruraux qui va porter sur
les productions résiliantes qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire il y a
des expériences à élar pour développer
le miscantu sous herba éléphant pour
développer le lin pour développer le
chanvre l'objectif de cette mission
c'est d'avoir une vision consolidée au
plan national à la fois agronomique et
économique sur les opportunités de
nouvelles cultures
mieux adaptées au changement climatique
[Musique]
l'exploitation elle-même de
l'accompagner dans les changements à
opérer et il y aura une première une
prairie si je puis dire de 1500
exploitations cette année l'objectif
étant d'être en régime de croisière sur
10 000 exploitations par an
le troisième axe du varen c'est l'accès
raisonné à la ressource en eau je vous
donne quelques exemples de ce qui est
fait à la fin du mois de juillet un
décret a été pris pour
déterminer la méthode
sur les volumes prélevables or la
période de basseaux comme vous le savez
jusqu'à présent ce qui était réglementé
c'était les prélèvements en période des
tirages là l'objectif c'est de le faire
pour les périodes où il y a davantage
d'eau tout simplement partant de cette
idée que si on a une période sèche
beaucoup plus marquée on a aussi des
périodes
où l'eau est beaucoup plus abondante et
c'est le moment de pouvoir évidemment
constituer des stocks ce décret doit
être accompagné par une étude qui est
pilotée par l'inrae et l'OSB sur la
méthodologie de détermination des
volumes prélevables pour permettre
l'application de cette réglementation
à la fin du mois de janvier une
instruction complémentaire a été prise
sur les plantes territoriaux de gestion
des eaux
pour résumer à l'extrême cette
instruction
donne au préfet coordonnateur pour
chaque ptge
la possibilité au bout d'un certain
délai de débats et d'échanges
d'arbitrer de prendre les grandes
orientations pour pouvoir faire
déboucher ses démarches ptge nous
travaillons aussi sur la réutilisation
des eaux usées traitées en industrie
il y a un projet de décret et un projet
d'arrêté qui ne sont pas encore
stabilisés l'idée étant que le décret
fixe un cadre d'ensemble et que l'arrêté
puisse après avis de landeces définir
des couples entre l'usage et les
précautions à prendre dans la
réutilisation des eaux usées de traitées
plus on s'approche de la production
alimentaire plus il bien entendu
augmenter le niveau de précaution
le varen a permis aussi
un soutien aux travaux d'hydraulique
agricole 45 millions d'euros du plan de
relance l'an passé complété par 2000000
cette cette année
il y a également toute une série
d'appels à projets d'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt au titre de
France 2030
je voudrais citer un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt démonstrateur
territoriaux où il y a de lauréat qui
correspondent aux Varennes un projet
d'irrigation
dans le sud de l'Hérault et du Gard
à partir d'eau
usé traité et en autre projet beaucoup
plus axé sur une nouvelle technologie de
la Chambre d'Agriculture des Pays de la
Loire
enfin il y a un chantier à poursuivre à
développer qui est celui de
l'optimisation des ouvrages hydrauliques
existants un inventaire par
photosatellite a été fait nous avons sur
le territoire national environ 350
000 réserves de plus de 0,1 nectar de
superficie
c'est un patrimoine qui est colossal et
le l'inspection générale du
développement durable est en train de
travailler sur la méthodologie pour
pouvoir
utiliser
cette masse d'information dans les
territoires parce que une fois qu'on a
la photographie il faut savoir qui est
propriétaire de l'ouvrage dans quel état
et l'ouvrage est-ce qu'il y a à
proximité ou non des exploitations qui
peuvent être intéressés par l'irrigation
comment on gère la relation entre le
propriétaire de l'ouvrage et les
exploitations et bien entendu tout
l'aspect des conséquences
environnementales donc voilà quelques
exemples de ce qui est fait au titre des
24 mesures du varen je voudrais conclure
en insistance sur un point qui est
particulièrement important c'est que le
varen c'est un équilibre d'ensemble
l'équilibre entre la protection de
l'agriculture mais surtout les deux
démarches d'adaptation de l'agriculture
au changement climatique et d'accès
raisonner à la ressource le Varennes
c'est l'une et l'autre de ces grandes
orientations c'est par l'une contre
l'autre c'est pas l'une sans l'autre
c'est vraiment cette équilibre
d'ensemble adaptation et accès raisonné
à la ressource je vous remercie
si Monsieur chargé
merci monsieur le Président Madame les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs merci
de votre invitation à cette table ronde
sur les défis posés par la réflexion de
la ressource en eau nous avons eu
l'occasion d'échanger sur les enjeux de
l'eau et du changement climatique lors
du rapport qui a été produit par votre
délégation à la prospective et vous avez
même pu visiter un aménagement
hydroélectrique ce qui est toujours
intéressant parce que c'est sur le
territoire en fait sur le terrain qu'on
s'aperçoit de ce qui peut se passer ce
vivre sur sur nos territoires avec le
changement climatique et la gestion de
l'eau
EDF hydro c'est l'entité de DF qui qui
gère les aménagements hydroélectriques
en France métropolitaine
l'hydroélectricité et je tenais à le
souligner ici on l'oublie trop souvent
c'est la première des on-r donc la
première des énergies renouvelables
c'est une énergie renouvelable
souveraine flexible stockable donc elle
coche beaucoup de cases
c'est sans doute une très ancienne
énergie ça c'est sûr mais elle a encore
de très beaux atouts dans le cadre de la
transition énergétique que nous vivons
et que la France est en train de mener
et justement pour toutes les qualités
que je viens d'énumérer par ailleurs
elle s'inscrit dans le temps long de la
vie de nos territoires et contribue à
leur dynamisme avec l'emploi la
fiscalité le multi-usage de l'eau et j'y
reviendrai et heureusement vous ne
l'avez pas oublié lors des débats sur la
loi d'accélération des ENR puisque vous
avez
pu contribuer à l'introduire dans cette
loi d'accélération des ENR puisqu'elle
n'y était pas et c'était bien dommage
puisque cette première des ENR n'était
pas représentée dans cette loi qui avait
pour but de pousser le son développement
et donc pour ça soyez en remercier et on
compte sur vous encore dans les cette
année 2023 qui est un peu clé sur
l'énergie justement pour la pousser dans
les différents véhicules législatifs que
vous pourrez avoir à travailler cette
année
son autre spécificité c'est qu'elle
touche à l'eau qui est un autre bien
commun essentiel il y a l'énergie qui
est un bien commun et l'eau qui est un
bien commun et donc nous sommes
hydroélectricien à la croisée de ces
deux biens communs EDF hydroger ainsi
pour le compte de la collectivité
puisque ce sont des concessions d'État
quelques milliards de mètres cubes de
surface dans les barrages et les retenus
en France métropolitaine cette eau qui
sert principalement donc à la production
hydroélectrique
usage essentiel notamment pour s'adapter
aux variations de consommation
traditionnelle en journée mais aussi au
pointes notamment en hiver cette
océros aussi d'autres usages
l'irrigation l'eau potable le tourisme
la navigation sur le Rhin par exemple
mais aussi la préservation de la
biodiversité nous sommes donc à la
croisée d'un certain nombre de chemins
et elle contribue au refroidissement des
centrales nucléaires comme monsieur le
président l'a indiqué tout à l'heure
deux tiers de nos concessions
hydroélectriques ont déjà aujourd'hui
d'autres usages que la production
d'hydroélectricité deux tiers
EDF veillant donc à mener la gestion des
aménagements hydroélectriques en
concertation avec les acteurs locaux de
l'eau elle participe aux instances de
gouvernance et de gestion nationale et
locale de l'eau elle a su montrer cet
été son sens du service public et de
l'intérêt général puisque sur la Durance
nous avons arrêté de produire de
l'électricité fin février pour permettre
justement de restocker ses pensées et de
permettre les usages qui sont importants
pour l'été notamment l'agriculture
puisque il y a une forte demande
agricole sur cette chaîne Durance
l'hydroélectricité ne consomme pas d'eau
c'est important aussi de l'avoir en tête
dans nos réflexions collectives sur le
changement climatique on la retient
quand elle est abondante et on la
relâche quand on en a besoin elle
participe donc à l'atténuation des
effets du changement climatique
on a eu un été difficile on pourra y
revenir si vous le souhaitez le rôle de
DF pour accompagner l'État et les
collectivités locales a été saluées
c'est sans doute la chance pour la
France que de bénéficier ainsi d'un
acteur hydroélectrique au service de la
gestion de l'eau sur les territoires de
montagne
EDF a accumulé une expérience de gestion
de l'eau qui peut servir dans les temps
compliqués vers lesquels nous allons
collectivement sur nos territoires il
nous faut néanmoins intégrer les
différentes temporalités de la gestion
de l'eau et les différents niveaux de
décision entre les différents enjeux de
l'eau du point de vue énergétique le
stockage derrière les barrages vise à
conserver l'eau pour produire
principalement l'hiver
du point de vue des autres usages cette
eau doit être relâché pour le
multi-usage plutôt l'été même s'il faut
pas non plus négliger les équilibres
offre demande qui peut y avoir l'été
notamment cet été 2022 nous avons eu
plusieurs fois la nécessité pour
l'hydroélectricité de produire pour
apporter de la puissance au système
notamment en juillet début juillet
nous devons ainsi répondre à des enjeux
de sécurité du système électrique à la
maille nationale voie régionale et en
même temps répondre à des enjeux de
multi-usage de l'eau au niveau local
concilier ces deux dimensions haut et
énergie dans des contextes temporels et
spatiaux aussi différents n'est pas
chose aisée et ça il faut le qu'on
l'intègre tous collectivement nous avons
depuis des années adapté notre gestion
pour y faire face nous relâchons des
centaines de millions de mètres cubes
chaque année pour d'autres usages tout
en assurant les besoins de flexibilité
du système électrique puisque c'est la
qualité première de l'hydroélectricité
la mobilisation des réservoirs
hydrauliques est déjà largement activée
comme je vous le disais deux tiers des
concessions hydrales électriques ont
déjà d'autres usages de l'eau que la
production d'énergie dans beaucoup
d'endroits le fait que les barrages
hydroélectriques servent d'autres usages
ainsi masquer le besoin d'adaptation au
changement climatique des bénéficiaires
nous avons tenu en 2022 dans un contexte
doublement inédit une sécheresse
exceptionnelle l'été qui nous a conduit
à déstocker bien plus que la normale 800
millions de mètres cubes soit en 2022
donc soit 60% de plus que la moyenne
2015 2021
et plusieurs retenus ont été totalement
vidés à la limite de la vidange
et en même temps gérer un risque sur la
provisionnement en énergie pour l'hiver
puisqu'on s'attendait un hiver très
tendu ce qui sera encore le cas cette
année 2023 puisqu'on s'attend un été
déjà tendu du point de vue de l'eau et
puis on s'attend à un hiver compliqué
encore sur l'équilibre offre de monde
sur le réseau et donc ce qui nous a
conduit à devoir constituer en même
temps que cette gestion utilisage de
l'eau des réserves d'eau suffisantes
pour passer l'hiver et les pointes de
consommation
dernièrement il y a aussi des limites
même purement physique à l'exercice et
des leurs éventuels mobilisations
supplémentaires des retenus et
hydroélectriques ne seront pas une
solution miracle d'une part parce que
nos installations ne sont pas
géographiquement toujours localisées là
où se trouve les besoins en eau je crois
que le directeur de l'eau et la
biodiversité monsieur Thibault l'a
exprimé aussi devant vous lors de son
audition d'autre part parce que les
volumes seraient insuffisants en fait
pour couvrir l'ensemble des besoins ceci
étant rendu croissant par les besoins
liés au changement climatique
notre conviction profonde et qu'il n'est
pas question de sacrifier une des
dimensions au énergie au bénéfice de
l'autre notre défi collectif est bien de
réussir de front et la transition
énergétique et la gestion durable de la
ressource en eau pour nous il est donc
nécessaire et j'en terminerai par là
au-delà de la contribution des
réservoirs hydro en régime normal qui
continuera de trouver de nouvelles
solutions face aux besoins d'eau soit
par l'arceau briété des usages soit par
la constitution de nouvelles capacités
de stockage de continuer à développer
l'hydroélectricité pour les besoins du
système électrique notamment parce qu'on
aura de plus en plus besoin de
flexibilité nous considérons qu'il y a
encore du potentiel de développement en
France et en outre-mer que ce soit dans
un cadre purement énergétique ou
multi-usage de l'eau monsieur le préfet
n'a parlé équilibré comme d'oppressés
d'écesseurs ont su le faire sur la
Durance qui est un bel exemple ou
justement au titre du multi-usage de
l'eau énergie et agriculture on a
construit un bel ensemble je vous
remercie
merci
monsieur Pellegrini
monsieur le Président Madame les
sénatrices monsieur les sénateurs
bonjour merci de l'invitation à cette
table ronde pour des sujets qui nous
animent à la Fédération depuis au moins
pour certaines adhérents de puissance 50
ans donc je vais essayer de dresser
rapidement mon propos liminaire autour
de deux idées tout d'abord le constat
tel qu'il s'impose à nous et puis
projeter les solutions qui existent
d'ores et déjà pour faire face à cette
situation extrêmement difficile
peut-être ouvrir ensuite sur quelques
réflexions de fonds tout d'abord le
constat je crois que nous devons pas
nous tromper l'été 2022 n'a pas été un
été
exceptionnellement chaud je crois qu'on
fait face à des périodes sèches de plus
en plus rapides et je peux d'ores et
déjà vous annoncer que l'été 2023 compte
tenu de l'état des nappes aujourd'hui en
termes de niveau et laitiers
2022 en France le chiffre est pas
complètement
encore précis approximatif plus de 500
communes en France ont été privés d'eau
potable cet été
et aujourd'hui nous devons nous
anticiper à des sujets extrêmement
clairs lorsqu'on regarde les projections
de Météo France sur certaines parties du
territoire et quand on observe l'étiage
des fleurs et la concentration de
pollution du fait de la baisse du niveau
des nappes et les pièges sévères de nos
fleurs je crois que l'état de la
ressource aujourd'hui en France est en
danger
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui peu de gens
peuvent le contredire s'ajoutent à cela
un retard structurel d'investissement
des services d'eau et d'assainissement
et ce constat a été dressé avant l'été
2022 nous investissons en France un peu
plus de 6 milliards d'euros par an dans
les services d'eau et d'assainissement
la filière a fait un travail
en 2021 ou 2020 je ne sais plus
pardonnez-moi cette imprécision qui
consiste à dire que nous avons un retard
d'investissement d'une quinzaine de
milliards d'euros sur les 5 ans qui
viennent pour anticiper les effets du
changement climatique donc la ressource
sera ici le fait qu'elle seraifie
complique énormément les traitements en
qualité puisque encore une fois les
contrats de pollution s'intensifie face
à des services d'eau et d'assainissement
dont le patrimoine sérum ça c'est la
situation collective que nous devons
gérer ensemble
les solutions existent elles sont
nombreuses tout d'abord je crois que
nous devons être extrêmement prudent sur
la qualité et l'efficacité des services
d'eau en France on parle beaucoup ça
défrayer la conique du fameux rendement
de réseau c'est à dire c'est quand il
est eau que nous perdons en distribuant
l'eau dans les réseaux et qui n'arrivent
pas au robinet de l'usager en France le
rendement de réseau est de 80%
c'est-à-dire qu'on perd grosso modo un
litre d'eau sur 5 dans les réseaux ce
qui est plutôt dans les épures hautes de
l'Europe néanmoins ce rendement moyen
cache une disparité et une hétérogénité
importante dans les territoires en
France certains territoires ruraux
semi-ruraux ont des rendements de réseau
entre 160 et 70% parce que la densité de
population est pas la même parce que
l'effort d'investissement est encore
plus considérable donc
cette affichage qui est plutôt cohérent
cache une disparité importante qu'il
nous faudra traiter là aussi les
solutions existent aujourd'hui un réseau
de distribution d'eau en France à une
moyenne de vie de 150 ans
parce que le taux de renouvellement est
grosso modo de 0,7 %. or il faudrait
passer à 1,5% parce qu'on sait très bien
que la vie
utile d'un réseau en France c'est plutôt
entre 110 et 80 ans il faudrait rien que
sur ce sujet spécifique rajouter un
milliard par an néanmoins des solutions
de digitalisation développée par nos
entreprises existent parce que ce qui
est extrêmement important c'est la
connaissance du patrimoine de manière à
savoir ou investir quand et comment de
manière à ce que les investissements
soient les plus efficaces les Français
veulent participer au changement
climatique là aussi des solutions
existent les compteurs d'eau
intelligents qui permettent de tracer
donc la consommation d'eau au quotidien
mais qui permettent surtout aux citoyens
et aux usagers de se positionner face à
leur profil de consommation d'eau et au
changement climatique
aujourd'hui le sujet de l'eau est un
sujet national je suis toujours surpris
de voir à quel point nos concitoyens ne
connaissent pas complètement le cycle de
l'eau et le fait de les intégrer dans ce
dispositif pour leur permettre d'exercer
leur sobriété permet aussi de les
éduquer sur des politiques publiques
qu'il est concerne
la deuxième catégorie de solutions que
nous essayons de pousser et semble que
nous ayons été écoutés c'est la
réutilisation des eaux usées la France
est un mauvais élève en Europe cette
fois puisque nous réutilisons en France
un peu moins de 1% des autres traités
utilisés contre 14% en Espagne 8% Italie
l'agriculture espagnole utilise très
largement l'eau réutilisé pour irriguer
son agriculture de produits d'ailleurs
qui sont consommés en France les
technologies existent elles sont
maîtrisées et nous pouvons les déployer
nous avons proposé de passer à 10% ce
qui pourrait permettre d'approvisionner
de 500 millions de mètres cubes
c'est-à-dire 15% des besoins agricoles
l'irrigation de manière à pouvoir
soulager d'autant la ressource on parle
beaucoup de réutilisation des eaux mais
la réalimentation des nappes et aussi un
dispositif extrêmement intéressant qui
consiste à ré présenter les nappes
l'hiver de manière à faire face au Pic
l'été évidemment il ne faut pas oublier
dans ce dispositif des sujets qui
concernent moins nos entreprises mais
qui sont extrêmement performants c'est
la sécurisation
d'alimentation entre un système et un
autre puisque la ressource est en locale
et les compétences dans le local
aujourd'hui les systèmes d'eau dans les
territoires sont pas sécurisés l'un
l'autre donc là le gouvernement a
développé 100 milliards au début de
l'été pour s'assurer justement que
l'alimentation et la sécurisation de
système entre fonctionné je crois que
c'est un système extrêmement important
doubler de la désimperméabilisation des
sols de nos villes de notre territoire
qui doit aussi contribuer à réglementer
mieux la ressource donc des solutions
existent pour essayer collectivement de
mettre en place des actions performance
peut-être deux réflexions pour conclure
aujourd'hui nous avons en France un
système d'eau extrêmement performant qui
a fait école et qui a raillonné dans le
monde entier nous devons non seulement
le défendre mais le pousser de manière à
ce qui reste la référence dans le monde
le système de compétences est
décentralisé au niveau des collectivités
territoriales l'état évidemment légifère
et les agences de l'eau font notre point
de vue un travail remarquable de
péréquation et de répartition des
investissements néanmoins ce système
aujourd'hui ne permet pas d'avoir une
vision
programmatique au niveau national de
manière à combler les retards et les
lacunes et anticiper les effets du
changement climatique je crois que les
constats sont extrêmement clairs le
varen agricole de l'eau a fait un
travail remarquable de même que les
assises de l'eau qu'ils ont précédé ont
fait un travail remarquable l'idée et
objectif qui doit être le nôtre à notre
avis aujourd'hui c'est de passer de ces
constats à l'action une action
coordonnée synchronisée qui permettent
d'anticiper les effets du changement
climatique merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs donc
je suis vasquination je viens d'inrae je
viens plus précisément du e d'inrae
puisque on a rajouté à ce à ce beau
sigle un e lorsqu'il a
absorbéa et ertea c'était la l'institut
qui s'occupait essentiellement
de l'hydrologie de l'hydrobiologie et de
beaucoup de questions d'eau
moi ma spécialité en tant que
scientifique c'est je suis hydrologue et
si je viens aujourd'hui pour aborder
devant vous les questions de ressources
en eau je dois dire que je suis toujours
un peu un peu gêné de ce mot ressources
en eau
parce que je pense que la question des
ressources en eau scientifiquement et
parfois est toujours assez complexe
malgré l'apparente simplicité et parfois
mal posée par exemple monsieur le
sénateur a évoqué ces deux chiffres
l'agriculture utilise en 9%
des prélèvements 45% de la consommation
donc c'est déjà deux chiffres différents
on se dit pourquoi deux chiffres et
ensuite on pourrait se dire mais sont
des pourcentages qui sont calculés sur
sur quel chiffre et en fait ce ne sont
pas des pourcentages qui sont calculés
sur une ressource qui est mal définie
sont des pourcentages qui sont
calculés sur
la totalité des écoulements de la France
et la totalité est une partie de mon
message c'est que la totalité des
écoulements de notre pays ne peut pas
constituer ce qu'on appelle une
ressource
car il faut bien une ressource c'est
bien ce que nous les hommes pouvant
utiliser
le fait qu'on qualifie la ressource de
naturel
ne change rien à cela
voilà ensuite si les mots ont une
importance
et je pense que donc on se trompe
souvent en utilisant le mot ressource
on complexifie la question parfois en
parlant de ressources souterraines et de
ressources de surface les ressources
souterraines
constituent à la fois un stock et un
flux les ressources de surface
l'écoulement des rivières constituaient
essentiellement un flux et les
ressources souterraines et les
ressources de surface ne sont pas
indépendantes si on
néglige et je pense que c'est
négligeable les ressources souterraines
qui alimentent directement les océans
donc il y a bien sûr des sources dans
les calanques de Marseille qui vont
directement à l'océan en réalité les
ressources souterraines sont également
en été des ressources de surface il n'a
pas plus dans notre pays en juillet et
pourtant dans beaucoup de rivières il y
avait encore de l'eau pas assez sans
doute mais il y avait de l'eau c'était
l'eau souterraine qui réapparissait
puisqu'elle est drainée par les par les
rivières
donc
j'ajouterai encore
un niveau de complexité mais c'est du
bon sens c'est on a qualifier l'ensemble
des écoulements de ressources ont
surestime la ressource mobilisable
puisque lors d'une crue sevenol très
intense ou une quantité faramineuse
d'eau passe dans les
dans les ruisseaux et dans les rivières
cette quantité elle n'est pas stockable
tout simplement nous ne disposons pas
des moyens de la stocker et donc elle ne
constitue pas une quantité que nous
pouvons utiliser
voilà
enfin dans le mot ressource il y a bien
la notion d'utilisation et ce que je
voulais ce qui a déjà été évoqué c'est
bien le fait que l'eau n'est elle est
utilisable de nombreuses façons et l'eau
peut être utilisable quand on la prélève
mais aussi elle peut être utilisable
quand on la laisse là où elle est
typiquement c'est le cas de la
navigation si on ne laisse pas à débit
qu'on peut qualifier de réserver pour la
navigation et bien les péniches ne
bougeront pas
voilà
nous en tant qu'être humain nous avons
la possibilité de convertir une plus
grande part une plus grande part de la
de l'écoulement naturel en ressources en
développant des stockages alors on le
fait depuis toujours et puis on le fait
dans le bassin de la Seine par exemple
c'est un une bonne illustration des des
stockages qui sont réalisés c'est ceux
qui sont faits par les grands lacs de
Seine et qui ont permis de réalimenter
la scène tout cet été nous n'avons pas
eu de problème je pense ni de production
d'eau ni de
navigation sur la scène mais c'est bien
parce que près de 60% de l'écoulement de
la scène c'était en réalité un
écoulement qui avait été stocké pendant
l'hiver et qui était
livré à la rivière voilà donc je pense
que
tout cela est très important et
peut-être que certains d'entre vous
noteront que je n'ai pas parlé
d'écologie alors souvent on invite
quelqu'un d'inraël pour parler
d'écologie des cours d'eau alors c'est
parce que je suis gêné par le mot
ressources qui me semble être un mot peu
adapté à cela mais il va de soi que
lorsque l'on mobilise
les écoulements naturels
il est essentiel dans laisser une part
non négligeable aux écosystèmes
aquatiques qui consiste qui constitue
une source très importante de
biodiversité à laquelle je pense les
Français sont très attachés
merci je vais donner la parole à
Stéphane demi
merci monsieur le président
je voudrais rebondir monsieur le
Président sur les propos que vous avez
tenus en introduction quand vous
évoquiez la sobriété nécessaire et la
modération de la consommation d'eau à
l'échelle nationale un peu d'ailleurs
comment là également au niveau de
l'énergie j'ai deux questions à poser à
nos invités et tout spécifiquement à
Monsieur Pellegrini une question
monsieur Pellegrini sur le gâchis
domestique et une question sur le gâchis
structurel en parlant de gâchis
domestique on le sait tous une simple
chasse d'eau défectueuse peut gaspiller
jusqu'à 25 litres d'eau par heure et il
n'y a pas de petit geste quand on est 68
millions à les faire pour reprendre
cette publicité et à propos de chasse
d'eau j'avais fait voter un amendement
lors du Grenelle de l'environnement à
l'Assemblée nationale pour la
récupération des eaux de pluie
utilisables dans les bâtiments publics
pour alimenter notamment les chasses
d'eau car je ne voyais pas l'utilité de
gaspiller 5 litres d'eau à chaque
utilisation
ce principe est-il en développant mais
vu quelques informations là-dessus et
plus largement qu'en est-il de la
réutilisation des eaux usées en France
qui représentent une des solutions
d'avenir à l'arrêtfaction de de l'eau
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs monsieur
Pellegrini nos voisins espagnols et
italiens sont en avance sur sur le sujet
concernant cette pratique de
réutilisation des eaux en sortie de
station d'épuration on a les techniques
alors quelles sont les frais et les
leviers pour activer et démocratiser
cette procédure en France ma deuxième
question porte sur le gâchis structurel
je le disais dans le JDD donc ce
week-end un article de Sébastien Martin
qui est le président de la terre
communalité de France et qui expliquait
que les sécheresses successives ne font
qu'accélérer la détérioration des
réseaux un milliard de mètre cube d'eau
se perd en fuite chaque année et nos
réseaux souffrent d'un
sous-investissement chronique au rythme
actuel dit-il il faudrait 150 ans pour
les renouveler en intégralité
et selon les observateurs le besoin
d'investissement est de 4 milliards
d'euros par an à l'échelle nationale je
voulais savoir si votre fédération celle
que vous présidez intervient sur le
sujet en termes de sensibilisation des
élus et d'une façon générale des
pouvoirs publics pour faire accélérer
ses
merci
merci monsieur le président
merci à nos intervenants de d'avoir
parlé de l'eau c'est vrai que c'est dans
un contexte de déréglement climatique la
gestion de l'eau doit être une priorité
non seulement pour l'alimentation en eau
potable mais aussi pour la souveraineté
alimentaire je crois qu'il faut pas
l'oublier
alors c'est vrai que on est dans une
période de raréfaction de la ressource
en eau
depuis quelques temps on marche sur les
eaux puisqu'on parle beaucoup de l'eau
depuis
notamment au Sénat mais aussi dans
beaucoup d'instances avec le varen
agricole de l'eau les tables rondes sur
l'eau les débats dans l'hémicycle nous
avons eu avec les agences de l'eau
le rapport d'information que nous allons
mettre en oeuvre avec mon collègue Hervé
gilet
on fait beaucoup de constats
mais finalement on transforme pas le
verbe en action
c'est vrai que vous l'avez dit l'état de
la ressource en eau et en danger
mais depuis 30 ans il faut savoir que
nous n'avons plus de politique de la
ressource en eau depuis plus de 30 ans
ne s'occupe plus de de cette
problématique que ça soit quantitatif et
qualitatif
et récemment
on a eu un débat
au Sénat et on a un certain nombre à
avoir proposé à certains de
solutions alors qu'ils viennent
peut-être un peu tardivement mais il
n'est jamais trop tard pour pour le
faire à la savoir c'est une politique de
nouveaux barrages pour le soutien de
l'étiage
de nos rivières également relancer
l'hydroélectricité parce que c'est un
sujet que nous avons évoqué et que
Monsieur de chercher à charger à évoquer
c'est une énergie renouvelable qui
consomme pas d'eau
c'est le rechargement des nappes par
injection
on en parle très peu et ici ça peut être
une solution
c'est la réutilisation des eaux usées
alors qui pose un problème parce que
sur le plan financier quand vous êtes à
côté d'une grande agglomération vous
avez un volume suffisant pour faire de
la l'irrigation sur des cultures
proximité mais quand vous êtes dans des
campagnes où il y a très peu d'habitants
il va falloir mettre des kilomètres de
canalisation pour aller emmener l'eau
pour la réutiliser ça ça des coût
tout à fait énorme après il y a aussi la
dés la désalinisation
qui peut être évoqué et puis aussi la
simplification de la mise en place des
réserves de substitution parce que là
aussi on a un vrai problème on a vu ce
que ça pouvait donner notamment dans les
Deux-Sèvres il y a quelques temps
donc à partir de tous ces constats il
faut agir il faut des moyens financiers
importants et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui
notamment les agences de l'eau
sont limités en termes d'investissement
puisque on leur reprend dans les poches
un certain nombre de financement avec le
fond mordant on n'a pas la capacité de
d'investir suffisamment
alors que dans le même temps il y a des
priorités qu'on devrait mettre en oeuvre
et mon collègue parlait de du milliard
de mètres cubes perdus dans les
canalisations ça c'est un vrai sujet de
l'eau il y en a mais on en perd déjà 20%
de l'eau qui est traitée en plus qui
coûte cher
donc il faut qu'on mette des priorités
pour financer la réhabilitation de ces
canalisations parce que ça nous
permettrait de récupérer de l'eau
soit pour l'eau potable déjà ça
coûterait moins cher au contribuable et
puis aussi pour l'irrigation donc voilà
il y a des il y a des solutions il y a
des priorités il y a des exemples à
suivre Israël est un exemple assez
exceptionnel parce que avec peu d'eau
ils font beaucoup de choses et donc on
pourrait s'en inspirer l'Espagne aussi
mais bon l'Espagne a maintenant aussi
d'autres d'autres problèmes pour remplir
leurs réserve c'est un peu compliqué
moi ce que je voulais poser aussi comme
question
devant nous faire une nouvelle loi sur
l'eau parce que la dernière loi sur
l'eau date de si mes souvenirs sont
montés
est-ce qu'on a pas quelque chose à
revoir dans ce domaine-là et puis quand
elle retarde d'investissement bon je
l'ai évoqué mais c'est le sujet aussi
prioritaire
merci j'ai donné la parole à Monsieur
gilet bien monsieur Gold et à Madame
Bonnefoy monsieur Favreau ce sera les 6
premiers et puis après
merci monsieur le Président je remercie
l'ensemble des intervenants vous avez
tracé un certain nombre de pistes et de
perspective qui nous faudra sans doute
creuser encore un peu plus et voir de
quelle manière factuellement nous
pouvons essayer de créer une politique
des moyens qui nous permettrait
d'aboutir sur un certain nombre de
sujets
je voudrais vous interpeller et
peut-être aller un peu plus loin sur sur
quelques-uns notamment tout d'abord sur
l'affirmation de la gestion et de la
politique de l'eau dans les politiques
d'urbanisme il semblerait qu'aujourd'hui
ça soit un axe qui est quand même
important et sur lequel il faudrait
peut-être avancer de manière plus forte
la gestion de l'eau en termes de
ressources pourrait s'intégrer
aujourd'hui dans le cadre des scottes et
pourrait également au niveau des pluies
et des PLU nous permettent de développer
un certain nombre de stratégies
notamment sur la gestion du fil de l'eau
la gestion des eaux pluviales par
exemple mais donc bien de prendre la
ressource en eau en termes d'accueil des
nouveaux habitants comme une stratégie
territoriale pour l'intégrer donc d'une
manière forte dans les politiques
d'urbanisme et j'aimerais avoir votre
avis sur le sujet puisque aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas encore réellement le cas et
donc là il y a une stratégie
territoriale qui pourrait être affirmée
concernant les concessions
hydroélectriques un sujet majeur se pose
aujourd'hui avec la mise en demeure de
l'Europe sur l'évolution donc de ces
concessions et la mise en concurrence
j'aurais également avoir votre avis sur
ce sujet là puisque de fait si tel était
le cas il pose bien sûr la l'affirmation
et la nécessité de créer donc des
cahiers des charges qui soient
respectueux de l'ensemble des soutiens
des tirages et de l'ensemble des
disponibilités nécessaires dans le cadre
de cette mise en concurrence donc c'est
un sujet qui est absolument majeur
sur les concessions hydroélectriques
autres sujets importants c'est le
développement des solidarités
interbassins ça a été un peu évoqué mais
on peut également les affirmer ce qu'on
turbine pas d'un côté peut permettre de
créer des lachures supplémentaires et
donc on peut turbiner un peu plus d'un
côté pour créer des stocks effectivement
qui permettent d'avoir des lachures
utiles en termes de soutien des tirages
et donc c'est solidarité international
sont également un sujet qui est
particulièrement important vous avez
abordé également des questions de
sobriété aujourd'hui de l'usage qui pose
la question d'une part de l'affirmation
de la recherche appliquée aujourd'hui
sur les techniques agricoles sur
lesquels on manque de visibilité
justement en termes de stratégie quelles
sont les stratégies aujourd'hui
nationales comment sont-elles déclinées
en subsidiarité pour affirmer une
recherche qui nous permettrait d'avancer
sur un certain nombre de technologies et
de pratiques qui seraient beaucoup plus
utiles il y a un manque d'éclairage par
ce sujet là la tarification différenciée
pourrez nous amener également à évoluer
vers une forme de sobriété est-ce que
c'est un sujet qui a été travaillé à
différents niveaux et puis je terminerai
en termes de gouvernance faut-il
clarifier aujourd'hui les compétences
entre les collectivités territoriales
Région Département toutes celles-ci est
en membres des syndicats et des comités
de bassin y a-t-il une évolution en
termes de gouvernance pour avoir une
meilleure efficacité aujourd'hui je vous
remercie
ce sujet à clarification des compétences
mais ça va devenir urgent monsieur gold
merci monsieur le Président merci aux
différents intervenants pour leur propos
alors on assiste depuis plusieurs années
à des sécheresses successives avec des
débits très réduits dans de nombreuses
rivières alors certaines époques de
l'année même on a des débits qui sont
principalement assurés par les rejets de
station d'épuration ce qui a pour
conséquence évidemment la concentration
des polluants
or les pompages dans les nappes
alluviales alimentent une grande partie
de nos concitoyens alors on a beaucoup
parlé de quantité d'eau mais peut-être
aussi nous apporter quelques éléments ou
quelques ébauches de solutions sur la
qualité de l'eau et notamment sur les
conséquences de ces concentrations de
polluants conséquence en termes de
traitement nouveau certainement à mettre
en place
conséquences en termes d'obligation
d'analyses certainement de plus en plus
précise et puis conséquence aussi en
matière de biodiversité dans les
rivières et notamment sur la faune
piscicole
merci la parole est à Nicole Bonnefoy
oui merci Président je voudrais
remercier les intervenants
et j'ai plusieurs questions d'abord
malgré des précipitations importantes en
janvier l'Observatoire Régional de la
biodiversité constate que seul 14 % des
nappes phréatiques ont retrouvé des
niveaux satisfaisants ainsi mon
département la Charente et
particulièrement touchée par le
phénomène de sécheresse et de
raréfaction de la ressource en eau
concernés au premier chef les
agriculteurs et vous l'avez évoqué tout
à l'heure même s'il dispose de réserves
en eau ou depuis redoute l'extinction de
la ressource et donc de leur activité
certains ont pris les devants en
modifiant leur culture par exemple en
diminuant leur production de maïs très
gourmands en eau pour plus de blé ou de
soja ou du chanvre il y a donc un vrai
travail à faire pour aider les
agriculteurs d'abord pour connaître les
sols et l'état de la ressource afin de
déterminer les conversions et les
transitions agricoles à faire donc ma
question est ne pourrait-on pas
envisager un grand plan d'accompagnement
des agriculteurs pour adapter leur
culture en vue de en vue de préserver la
ressource en eau des labels par exemple
pourraient être créés en lien avec les
collectivités qui généralisent
aujourd'hui des plans alimentaires
territoriaux ambitieux et c'est le cas
dans mon département donc quels sont vos
pistes de réflexion pour développer et
soutenir les filières à faible impact
sur la ressource en eau et ma deuxième
question
concerne les paiements pour services
environnementaux qui représente un
levier d'accompagnement inédit pour les
collectivités les agences de l'eau pour
anticiper les évolutions climatiques et
réaliser la transition agroécologique
est-ce que sur ces PSE plan paiement
pour service et environnementaux vous
avez étudié les premiers retours des
appels à projets réalisés je vous
remercie pour vos réponses merci la
parole de Monsieur Favreau puis après on
donnera la parole à nos intervenants
pour réponses merci
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
moi aussi
remercier les quatre intervenants ma
question
concernera peut-être plus le premier
d'entre eux monsieur vaut
dont le propos m'a paru correspondent
plus
aux
discussions qui anime depuis quelques
mois voire quelques années le
département dans le suis sénateur c'est
à dire les Deux Sèvres
je voulais d'abord dire que le
département des Deux-Sèvres a une
particularité géologique c'est que le
nord du département est sur le massifers
signal le sud et en zone karstique on
est sur du calcaire et donc la pratique
des agriculteurs qui se trouvent sur le
sud sur des zones de grandes cultures
consiste
à faire des forages pour aller chercher
l'eau dans des dates profondes c'était
la pratique bon qui a été critiqué à
juste titre car les nappes profondes ont
du mal à se renouveler rapidement donc
on a imaginé le système des fameuses
bassines c'est-à-dire
ces retenu de substitution qui consiste
à prélever l'eau au moment des périodes
de pluie en hiver et au début du
printemps
dans les nappes de surface appelons les
nappes phréatiques mais je crois que
c'est un beau qui peut-être discuté et
pour
remplir des retenues artificiels à ces
importantes qui permettent de diriger
les grandes cultures au moment de la
pousse des plantes
il y a là-dessus toute une polémique je
pense pour ma part que l'agriculture a
besoin d'eau on peut difficilement
empêcher les agriculteurs d'utiliser de
l'eau
je poserai une question sur le mode
d'irrigation tout à l'heure mais je
voudrais savoir
parce que le mode qui a été opéré
c'est-à-dire la constitution de ces
retenues d'eau et donc
l'irrigation des grandes cultures me
paraît quelque chose de normal si
d'abord
du côté de nos intervenants il y a une
solution différente pour utiliser
d'autres zones la question a déjà été
évoquée mais surtout puisque ça c'est
une question qui n'a pas été évoquée
quel est le mode d'arrosage ou
d'irrigation qui leur permet aujourd'hui
le plus opportun pour les cultures
puisque c'est vrai qu'on a plutôt des
arrosages avec des canons à eau qui sont
qui dépensent beaucoup d'eau qui ne sont
sans doute pas la meilleure méthode
d'économiser cette eau voilà les je
voulais poser
merci qui prend la parole en premier
parce que vous avez eu quelques
questions sur l'assainissement sur bien
volontiers merci merci beaucoup pour vos
questions donc je vais essayer de les
aborder donc dans la question de
l'efficacité et de la sobriété il y a
évidemment deux questions comment on
peut accompagner les usagers dans leur
consommation d'eau et comment on peut
faire en sorte que les réseaux de
distribution d'eau soit plus efficaces
s'agissant du premier volet sur la
sobriété aujourd'hui
les Français sont équipés à 40% de
compteur d'eau intelligent ça veut dire
que pour le reste des Français il
reçoivent leur facture d'eau basée sur
une relève une à deux fois par an autant
vous dire que le profil de consommation
d'eau et la capacité à infléchir son
profil et complètement déconnecté du
système de facturation c'est pour ça que
les compteurs intelligents et toutes les
applications développées autour
permettent de synchron à la fois l'usage
et la conscientisation je vous donne un
exemple aujourd'hui il est possible
grâce à nos applications de détecter des
paumes de douche non efficiente
je vous invite à changer vos pommes de
douche qu'elles se sont pas efficients
et il y a aussi et d'autres entreprises
sont extrêmement investies la
distribution de produits hydroéconomes
les plus jeunes générations adorent ce
sont ces douches qui changent de couleur
elles deviennent rouge vif lorsqu'elles
durent trop longtemps mais encore une
fois tout ça ne fonctionne que si les
citoyens et l'usagers voient l'effet de
leurs efforts dans leur facturation
d'eau
et il y a un usage qui est extrêmement
important et qui se développe aussi pour
certains bâtiments administratifs c'est
les recherches de fuite pour les maisons
secondaires pour les bâtiments
administratifs où il y a très peu de
mouvements le week-end de l'année je
pense aux établissements scolaires
particulièrement donc tout ça
aujourd'hui est possible la réflexion
peut être de fond que je vous sommets et
je suis loin de l'idéologie régie DSP le
système de facturation des services
d'eau et d'assainissement en France
repose sur un modèle volumétrique
je m'explique plus on consomme d'eau
comme c'est une division plus le prix au
mètre cube est bas donc comme on
s'oriente aujourd'hui vers une
conscientisation des usages et que nos
entreprises sont toujours poussées à
économiser l'eau ne faut-il pas et
encore une fois il y a des modèles
d'affaires aujourd'hui qui ne sont
proposés ou nos entreprises sont
rémunérés aux économies d'eau qu'elle
puisse générer à la fois dans la
distribution et aussi vis-à-vis des
usagers ça nous paraît une piste
extrêmement intéressante
sur maintenant les la réutilisation
évidemment la réutilisation est un sujet
majeur qui peut se concevoir à l'échelle
du bâtiment pour peu qu'on l'anticipe
dans je dirais l'aménagement immobilier
où on peut récupérer des eaux de pluie
et puis l'utiliser à l'intérieur du
bâtiment manière assez efficace c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué quand le
bâtiment existant et je reviendrai
évidemment sur la question de
l'aménagement du territoire aujourd'hui
il est essentiel de prendre en compte
les services essentiels dans leur
globalité dans l'aménagement du
territoire quand on fait un exercice
dans nos métiers où on essaye à
l'échelle d'un territoire de maillet les
différents réseaux on voit bien que il y
a une non convergence manifeste et je
suis évidemment pour tout comme la
Fédération évidemment à faire en sorte
que l'aménagement du territoire prenne
en compte les services essentiels dont
l'eau
sur le rendement de réseau notre constat
aujourd'hui c'est de dire qu'il faut
évidemment augmenter le taux de
renouvellement des réseaux de
distribution d'eau potable et
aujourd'hui un milliard de plus par an
nous paraît suffisant avec 5 6 ans
devant nous pour récupérer le retard que
nous avons et de passer à un taux de
renouvellement d'un virgule 5% qui
correspond à un âge moyen de 75%, la
problématique à mon avis qui est la
nôtre aujourd'hui c'est la fracture
territoriale sur ce rendement de réseau
encore une fois l'effort
d'investissement va peser davantage sur
des territoires où les densités sont
très faibles et où l'effort est
important et on va se retrouver sur un
territoire national où les métropoles
vont avoir des taux de rendement de
réseau extrêmement bons et des prix de
l'eau compétitif avec des territoires
ruraux et ce numéro qui va avoir des
prix de l'eau un peu plus cher et des
rendements de réseau extrêmement bas
donc il y a une de péréquation nationale
que les agences de l'eau traite en
partie qui ne peut pas être traités au
niveau de la collectivité territoriale
donc ça c'est à mon avis le sujet et je
rajoute que la connaissance du
patrimoine le patrimoine des services
d'eau et absolument considérable mais
lorsqu'il est invisible et enterré il
est plus difficile à cartographier il
nous paraît essentiel de mener des
efforts importants pour connaître ce
patrimoine de manière à faire en sorte
que les efforts d'investissement qui
seront nécessaires soient utilisés de
manière plus efficiente à savoir
investir le bon euro au bon endroit au
bon moment et nous avons là aussi de
l'innovation et des techniques en
fonction du mouvement des sols et puis
de certaines caractéristiques
géotechniques mais pas que pour savoir
où rénover en priorité mais la
rénovation des réseaux je reviens sur la
question de l'aménagement et territoires
suit souvent les aménagements de
mobilité par exemple parce que lorsque
il y a une nouvelle ligne de tram de un
territoire et bien on en profite pour
faire du rendement de mon réseau donc
c'est des questions qui sont intimement
liées
faut-il
une loi sur l'eau c'est à vous Mesdames
Messieurs dans votre sagacité d'y
réfléchir en tout cas ce que nous nous
constatons c'est que les collectivités
territoriales font face à des défis
considérables la compétence en eau est
assainissement fait sens parce que la
ressource est toujours locale il est
impossible d'avoir des politiques
efficaces parce que les problématiques
les sociologiques l'état du patrimoine
et local néanmoins aujourd'hui ce
système a accumulé trop de retard
contenu de l'accélération du changement
climatique donc peut-être que un coup de
pouce pour accélérer le niveau
d'investissement et de passer à une
action véritable qui nous protège tous
serait la bienvenue
et sur les questions de qualité d'eau et
de traitement je crois qu'elles sont
absolument considérables et là nous
devons avoir la vision d'ensemble du
cycle de l'eau il y a un projet
directive européenne sur
l'assainissement qui est en train d'être
discuté par les États membres
aujourd'hui
ce projet se propose de traiter les
résidus médicamenteux dans
l'assainissement les résidus
médicamenteux constituent 90% en gros
des micropollutions donc les traités
dans l'assainissement protègent d'autant
évidemment la capacité et la ressource
en eau si j'ai noté que mon voisin
n'aimait pas le mot ressources mais
c'est dans mon c'est dans ma sémantique
depuis très longtemps donc il faut qu'on
ait une vision d'ensemble et nous devons
aussi être extrêmement méfiantes des
polémiques qui consiste sur la qualité
d'eau à opposé traitement prévention il
faut évidemment faire les deux lorsque
dans l'Ouest français nous avons des
concentrations en pesticides dans les
nappes la prévention n'y fera rien il va
falloir amener des capacités de
traitement ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il
faille pas protéger la ressource en
amont donc là aussi il faut exercer
notre gouvernement territoire par
territoire pour faire en sorte de
protéger la qualité d'eau en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est que l'effet du
changement climatique est la raréfaction
de la ressource entraîne des sujets
induits importants sur la qualité que
nous devons faire face et je crois que
j'ai fini les parties qui me
concernaient monsieur le Président
[Musique]
mais merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais revenir sur deux sujets premier
sujet d'accompagnement des agriculteurs
face au changement climatique deuxième
sujet qui est celui de la performance de
l'irrigation alors sur l'accompagnement
des agriculteurs au moment des
conclusions du varen a été signée une
charte d'engagement entre
l'État les Chambres d'agriculture et les
différentes filières agricoles
en application de cette charte qui ont
été engagés les travaux des plans
d'adaptation des des filières et les
plantes territoriaux au niveau régional
donc ceci ça nous donne le cadre
ce dont nous allons avoir besoin dans
les dans les temps qui viennent parce
que le varen est une démarche évolutive
c'est de synthétiser de
capitaliser tous les éléments
d'évolution d'adaptation qui sont
recensés par ces différents travaux les
travaux des
des filières qui expriment tous
d'ailleurs un besoin important de de
recherche et de recherche appliquée sur
sur adaptation
c'est aussi ce que va nous dire le cgaer
sur les les productions résilientes et
ça va être également la mise en œuvre
des
levier d'adaptation qui font l'objet de
travaux comme je vous le disais des
instituts de l'inrae et de chambre
d'agriculture France au travers d'un
regroupement spécifique donc nous allons
avoir besoin de consolider la vision
sans doute pour aller au-delà de
l'initiative de chambre d'agriculture
France sur cet accompagnement des
exploitations
la performance de l'irrigation cette
un sujet qui est à l'évidence liée à la
question de la sobriété
le dernier recensement
agricole
montre que la surface agricole
utile irriguée à à nouveau progressé
entre de recensement 2010 de 2020
un peu de partout sur le territoire
c'est pas homogène ça a progressé en
Occitanie en Auvergne Rhône-Alpes mais
aussi dans les hauts de France
l'utilisation d'eau agricole a progressé
moins vite que la progression de la
superficie irriguée donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a une dimension performance de
l'irrigation qui a été prise en compte
par les agriculteurs
[Musique]
à avoir des capteurs dans les champs les
capteurs
analysent le niveau de confort de la
plante trop d'eau pas assez d'eau bon
niveau d'humidité et ça permet de donner
à l'agriculteur à l'exploitant le signal
du moment où il faut déclencher
l'irrigation pas trop tôt pas trop tard
le moment exact et ça passe par des
applications
qui qui arrive sur le téléphone portable
de
de l'exploitant voilà donc c'est toutes
ces gammes techniques qu'il faut
continuer à explorer ça fait partie
évidemment de du programme France 2030
ça fait partie aussi du initiative qu'on
appelle la troisième révolution agricole
justement pour aller toujours plus loin
dans cette performance et on voit bien
qu'il y a des démarches de manœuvre tout
à fait possible merci
une sur les financements des agences de
l'eau et le font mordant qui me paraît
intéressant et puis est-ce que vous avez
monsieur pellegrinien a répondu est-ce
qu'il faut une loi qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez au niveau
ministériel et puis je crois que la
troisième question mais il y en a une
cap oui et puis la quatrième question
c'est est-ce qu'il faut
avoir un chef de fil est-ce qu'il faut
revoir quelles sont les collectivités
qui pourraient gérer ça je pense que ces
questions sont importantes si vous
vouliez nous apporter une petite réponse
sur les PSE je n'ai pas les éléments
donc je peux pas vous répondre mais je
sais que c'est un outil que
un certain nombre de collectivités
souhaitent mettre en oeuvre j'ai en tête
un exemple
où il pourrait y avoir des zones
d'expansion des crues qui permettraient
de l'infiltration et en ayant
possiblement un système de PSE pour les
agriculteurs qui seraient concernés
faut-il une nouvelle loi sur l'eau il
m'appartient pas dit d'y répondre mais
je me suis référé au rapport de la
délégation à la prospective qui
elle-même ouvre la question la question
n'est pas n'est pas encore tranchée
alors après sur la question des des
compétences
au fond c'est la notion de chef de fila
des collectivités locales qui est qui
est sous-jacente
[Musique]
il y a peut-être un sujet que j'ai connu
d'expérience en zone rurale c'est vrai
que quand on a des tout petits syndicats
des eaux et là on est dans le domaine
adduction d'eau potable on n'est plus
dans le domaine plus seulement dans le
domaine agricole
on retrouve les sujets des capacités
financières des capacités techniques et
de et d'ingénierie on a peut-être
intérêt mais pour moi c'est une question
ouverte massifiée
on a peut-être intérêt à avoir des
structures un peu plus grosses pour
pouvoir conduire des projets notamment
des des projets d'interconnexion ce que
j'ai connu lors des sécheresses
2018-2019 c'était des petites structures
qui n'étaient pas interconnectées et qui
ont dû recourir de l'approvisionnement
par par noria de camions donc voilà ce
que je peux vous dire sur sur ces sujets
mais qui ne sont pas
tranchés je dirais
au niveau institutionnel peut-être
rapidement monsieur un ancien sur les
sur les retenues à la question de Madame
Bonnefoy si vous avez quelques éléments
mais assez rapidement ce qu'on a encore
8 7 8 8 devant
[Musique]
alors pour ce qui est de la question des
retenues
donc c'est une question qui est très
désagréable
en général qui m'apporte en général
beaucoup de beaucoup de critiques quand
j'y réponds donc je vais essayer d'être
plus prudent que que d'habitude ce que
je voudrais
non en fait sont mes collègues ce sont
j'ai des écologues et des hydrologues
dans mon unité et ne s'entendent pas sur
le l'opportunité des retenus et donc je
fais forcément des malheureux voilà donc
je voudrais commencer par dire que
une bassine alors c'est c'est un objet
mal
identifié moi j'ai tendance à dire
qu'une bassine c'est une retenue
qui comporte un lance plusieurs digues
plus d'une digue par rapport à un
barrage qui barrait une rivière mais
dans ce cas-là
le la méga bassine par excellence je
devrais dire plutôt la gigabassine les
gigabassine ce sont les retenues des
Grands Lacs de Seine vous savez que les
Grands Lacs de Seine ont quatre tenu
donc une sur l'Yonne classique et puis
trois retenu en dérivation sur l'Aube la
Marne
et la scène et donc ce sont des ce sont
des bassines qui sont en dérivation par
rapport au cours d'eau principaux qui
sont alimentés par un canal de
prélèvement et qui restitue l'eau au
cours d'eau par un canal à nouveau et
donc ces bassines ce qui est moi ce qui
me frappe en regardant les les Grands
Lacs de Seine c'est que ce sont des
gigabassines qui sont parfaitement
acceptés et qui sont même devenus des
des points chauds et pour les pour les
écologues pour la pour tous les
protecteurs des oiseaux
et donc je pense que une retenue n'est
pas condamnée à sa naissance à être
quelque chose de démoniaque voilà
ensuite les bassines des Deux-Sèvres
comme comme plusieurs d'entre vous l'ont
fait remarquer les Deux-Sèvres d'un
département qui est qui géologiquement
est très
il y a il y a en gros la première Sèvre
la Sèvre Nantaise qui coule sur du
granite et la Sèvre Niortaise qui coule
sur du calcaire et c'est pas du tout le
même environnement géologique
et les bassines dans le bassin versant
de la Sèvre Nantaise sont alimentées
essentiellement par des ruissellement
enfin les bassines et puis beaucoup de
je mes collègues en m'ont dit qu'il y en
avait plus de 11000 de décompter des il
s'agit pas de bassines il s'agit de plan
d'eau de plan d'eau dans certains sont
très anciens et donc
c'est tous ces plans d'eau ne posent pas
problème a priori ils sont ils
appartiennent au paysage
ce qui pose problème c'est
un type de bassine bien défini c'est le
type de bassine qui est alimenté par
pompage parce que ce type de bassine qui
est la première question que pose ceux
qui s'y opposent c'est pourquoi ne
laisserions-nous pas l'eau dans la nappe
superficielle je pense que
vous avez apporté enfin il y a une
logique hydrogéologique mais bien sûr le
fait de d'alimenter par pompage et
perçu par certains défenseurs de
l'environnement comme une intention de
de contourner les restrictions alors
qu'il pourrait il peut s'agir
on pourrait on pourrait défendre le
contraire moi je ne défendrai rien c'est
trop dangereux
dans mon cas personnel ce que j'aurais
tendance à dire c'est que une réserve de
substitution qui est alimentée par des
écoulements de surface
me semble plus acceptable
me semble avoir éventuellement des un
impact au moment du remplissage plus
fort mais au moins pas d'impact différé
puisque l'impact différé qui est redouté
c'est celui de cette eau souterraine qui
qui est destinée à s'écouler et qui est
destiné à rejoindre pour la
quasi-totalité des australiennes
françaises un cours d'eau avant de
rejoindre la mer et donc en fait
c'est ce que je vois
c'est ce que je peux je peux dire ce qui
semble le plus le plus critiquable dans
le cas des bassines c'est le ce sont les
bassines qui sont alimentés par pompage
et ensuite je pense qu'il y a un gros
travail de communication à faire puisque
il n'y a pas de raison pour que les
grands lacs de Seine d'ailleurs font un
énorme travail de communication sur sur
l'avantage de leur giga retenu sur les
sur les populations notamment
d'oiseaux et je pense c'est elle les
Grands Lacs de Seine sont très bien
acceptés il y a pas de raison que
d'autres ouvrages ne puissent pas être
acceptés de la même façon
ce que j'aurais voulu ajouter je
voudrais ajouter une chose sur les eaux
usées le recyclage des eaux usées alors
il faut bien savoir que le recyclage des
eaux usées se fait depuis très très
longtemps
mais on faisait du recyclage sans le
dire puisque dès lors que l'on rejette
avec une station d'épuration de l'eau
dans le dans un coup dans un cours d'eau
et bien en fait cette eau elle repart
dans le cycle naturel la seule exception
c'est bien sûr les communes littorales
qui rejettent en mer mais dès lors qu'on
n'est pas dans
dans une communauté littorale
on rejette et c'est rejets peuvent être
importants moi j'avais à nouveau un
chiffre dont on m'a parlé hier pour cela
que je m'en souviens encore sur la Sèvre
Niortaise il y a plus de rejets de
station d'épuration que de prélèvements
agricoles sur le bassin de la Sèvre
Nantaise
voilà donc c'est déjà quelque chose
d'important alors bien évidemment comme
l'un d'entre vous l'a remarqué ça peut
poser des problèmes de chimie des eaux
ça a un impact sur l'environnement parce
que nous savons tous que les stations
d'épuration est pure mais n'ont pas une
capacité à épurer en totalité et
notamment la question des perturbateurs
endocriniens donc de ces résidus de
médicamentseux se posent et dès lors que
les stations d'épuration ne sont pas
capables de traiter ces résidus
médicamenteux et bien il se retrouve
dans les cours d'eau et dans les cours
d'eau ils ont un impact sur
sur les poissons les plus visibles avec
des phénomènes de de changement de sexe
mais je pense sur l'ensemble de
l'écosystème et effectivement on a du
mal à évaluer
l'impact de cela cela n'empêche que de
toute façon les stations d'épurations
ont besoin ne peuvent pas stocker l'eau
et elle et elle ne peuvent pas je pense
ce serait du joueur de dire qu'une
station épuration pour avoir un
rendement de 100% et et produire une eau
distillée de je pense que c'est donc il
y aura toujours un flux de pollution et
il faudra toujours un flux d'eau donc
non pollué pour diluer une partie de ce
flux polluant alors je ne dis pas que
c'est bien ou c'est mal je dis que c'est
voilà pratiquement c'est ce que l'on
c'est ce que l'on observe merci Monsieur
cherget Merci monsieur le Président je
voulais répondre monsieur le sénateur
gilet sur ces questions sur les
concessions hydroélectriques alors c'est
vrai que la France
fait face à de mise en demeure de la
commission sur le sujet des concessions
hydrauliques une en 2015 et une en 2019
et c'est vrai que collectivement je
pense que à la fois gouvernement
les deux assemblées assemblées
nationales et Sénat se sont emparés de
ce sujet depuis quelques temps il faut
qu'on sorte du statu quo qui existe
depuis trop longtemps sur ce sujet et
qu'on trouve une solution juridique qui
permette de consolider ces concessions
hydroélectriques et de faire en sorte
que on préserve à la fois ce qui relève
de la souveraineté de l'eau et de la
souveraineté de l'énergie et je pense
que il faut qu'on arrive à sortir de ça
tout simplement aussi parce que si on
veut poursuivre le développement
hydroélectrique en France on est obligé
de en fait de résoudre en fait cette
problématique juridique avec la
commission puisque on a un projet qui
intéresse monsieur le sénateur angular
sur la truie hier sur un beau un beau
projet de développement justement de
surpuissant et de station de transfert
d'énergie par pompage et on ne peut pas
le faire puisque la Commission considère
que le projet ne peut pas se faire
puisque il y a cette mise en demeure qui
qui pense sur sur la France et qui n'est
pour l'instant n'est pas résolu
juridiquement donc pour poursuivre le
développement oui nous avons
collectivement intérêt à trouver une
solution juridique qui protège
collectivement nos intérêts français
bien compris juste pour pour continuer
sur votre question sur le soutien des
cages et les cahiers des charges je
dirais que au-delà de cette question que
vous posez très justement sur au moment
du renouvellement des concessions
comment intégrer cette chose là je pense
qu'en fait la question est plus complexe
et vous le savez sur votre bassin à
Bourg en fait c'est quelque chose qui
fait appel à l'intelligence collective
d'une part à de la souplesse et en fait
des choses se sont mises en place à
travers des conventions et vous savez
que avec sur adoure-garonne depuis 1993
en fait donc depuis très très longtemps
EDF à conventionné en fait avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et en lien avec
l'État pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait
toujours cette cette optimisation de
l'eau à la fois comme je le disais en
propose introductif entre l'énergie et
le multi-usage de l'eau et
intelligemment en 2022 nous avons
collectivement réussi à faire face aux
problématiques qui se faisaient posées
sur la Burgaronne d'une part pour
anticiper c'est lâcher d'eau pour le
multi-usage de l'eau puisque il y a eu
un besoin d'eau comme vous le savez
assez plus tôt dans la dans la saison et
de faire en sorte de au moment de l'été
où on a senti que l'hiver à l'aide
compliquée faire attention à nos qui
avait un coefficient énergétique les
plus importants sur ce bassin pour faire
en sorte justement de reconstituer les
stocks pour que on puisse passer l'hiver
sans trop de dommages d'un point de vue
équilibre offre demande énergétique donc
on voit bien que en fait on est on est
capable collectivement au-delà des
cahiers des charges de concession de
trouver des équilibres et là aussi où je
voulais
apporter aussi une autre une autre
réflexion et que vous connaissez bien
c'est qu'en fait ça ne se fait pas
concession par concession c'est bien sur
des ensembles et c'est bien ça ce qui
est aussi problématique dans la mise en
concurrence des concessions c'est qu'en
fait on perdrait cette optimisation
globale par bassin par valet par grande
vallées hydrographique dans laquelle on
peut en fait jouer sur les différentes
retenues et surtout préserver les
retenues qui ont un grand coefficient
énergétique qui justement servent à
servir la pointe
pour terminer sur votre question sur la
loi sur l'eau
j'ai pas de j'ai pas non plus à me
positionner sur ce sujet je dirais juste
que le nous participons avec Monsieur
Pelligrini d'ailleurs à au Cercle
français de l'eau qui est présidé par
Monsieur Burlot et on a eu trois
colloques l'année dernière sur justement
cette problématique de d'une nouvelle
loi sur l'eau avec pas mal de réflexion
donc je vous y rapporterai bien
volontiers parce que c'est des travaux
qui étaient très enrichissants et une
des conclusions c'était surtout de se
dire qu'en fait la politique de l'eau ne
doit pas être vu d'un point de vue
individuel autonome en fait la politique
de l'eau et on en a parlé plusieurs fois
ici et vos questions en témoigne elle
elles sont à la Confluence d'un certain
nombre d'autres politiques
urbanisme énergie agriculture et donc en
fait c'est plutôt ça qu'il faut qu'on
arrive collectivement à regarder c'est
comment on isole pas la politique de
l'eau mais qu'on fait en sorte qu'elle
soit la Confluence
de l'ensemble de ces enjeux
environnementaux énergétiques
urbanistiques économique parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'enjeux économiques à travers
le à travers cette ce sujet de l'eau
voilà ce que je voulais juste préciser
merci
le président ma question concernée la
qualité de l'eau et reprend pour partir
ce que disait monsieur Gold et Madame
Bonnefoy c'est-à-dire que nous avons été
très récemment et même aujourd'hui
interpellé par les déclarations de
l'ancêtre qui lance la procédure de
retrait du marché du métaux la chlore un
des pesticides les plus utilisés en
France non seulement parce que nous
avons atteint le taux limite fixé par la
Commission européenne mais surtout parce
que des mesures intermédiaires ont déjà
été mises en place et que les résultats
des études menées montrent que
malheureusement les résultats ne sont
pas satisfaisants et qu'aujourd'hui les
eaux souterraines sont encore
empoisonnés en quelque sorte par par ce
pesticide alors Monsieur vaux ma
question était la suivante est-ce que
les conclusions du varen de l'eau sont
encore à la hauteur de ces dégâts causés
sur l'environnement vous
écharte des plans d'accompagnement qui
sont certes intéressants et importants
et montrent des progrès considérables
mais comment est-ce qu'on met est-ce
comment est-ce qu'on va encore au delà
pour être à la hauteur finalement de ces
défis qui sont devant nous cette prise
de conscience que l'agriculture et bien
contribue largement au dégâts causés sur
la qualité de l'eau et aussi sur la
quantité d'ailleurs donc comment va-t-on
au delà c'est la question que je voulais
vous poser
merci la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Michel Huguette
merci monsieur le Président on sait
grosso modo financer l'Aude dès lors
qu'elle est une menace je pense
notamment au papy et à gemapi pour
lequel on a créé d'ailleurs une taxe ça
devient de plus en plus complexe dès
lors que l'eau est un bien de
consommation et on voit très bien dans
les budgets annexes ou l'eau doit
financer l'eau alors ma question est
simple comment faire face à ce mur
d'investissement notamment pour la
performance des réseaux et la réduction
des fuites 15 milliards vous le disiez
monsieur Pellegrini d'ici 5 ans est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas imaginer un peu ce
qui a été fait dans le domaine de
l'énergie à travers des contrats de
performance énergétique le contrat de
performance énergétique ça permettait un
investisseur tiers de se rémunérer entre
guillemets d'investir mais de se
rémunérer sur une part de l'économie
produite d'une certaine façon est-ce que
ce système vous paraît transposable à
l'eau et sinon quels sont les autres
pistes que l'on pourrait envisager
merci la parole est à même prévu
le président merci aux intervenants
alors moi je voulais revenir sur une
problématique qui a été évoquée par
Monsieur Bruno de charger et à savoir
sur les potentialités que vous avez
évoquées sur la création de STEP c'est à
dire de station de transfert des de par
pompage et qui permettrait justement de
pallier
à notre besoin d'électricité est-ce que
il y a ce que vous avez évoqué le projet
l'autre hier je lui sénatrice du Lot
donc voilà j'en connais un petit peu
aussi
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres projets dans
les cartons qui pourraient être mis en
oeuvre est-ce que cela correspond à nos
besoins de créer ces stations puisque je
rappelle à mes collègues puisque c'est
pas peut-être évident d'avoir compris ce
que c'était exactement c'est quand on a
un surplus d'électricité de pompelo pour
la mener en altitude à une altitude
supérieure ce qui a un stockage de
l'électricité en fait et quand on on a
besoin après de l'électricité de refaire
tomber l'eau en quelque sorte pas
gravité pour obtenir
le la mise en oeuvre d'un alternateur
qui produira l'électricité donc c'est un
stockage en fait d'électricité à la fois
un stockage d'eau mais un stockage
d'électricité qu'on a assez peu mobilisé
jusqu'à présent pour ma part j'ai déposé
régulièrement dans les projets de loi de
finance des des
dispositifs pour qu'on puisse mettre en
oeuvre plus facilement par des
différents subventions etc donc mon pur
perte un pardon pour l'instant alors ma
deuxième question c'est et en écho avec
mes collègues
nous avons constaté le constat est là
maintenant sur évidemment cette qualité
de l'eau qui se dégrade et j'ai
participé un colloque dans le cadre du
comité de bassin de Roland l'année
dernière sur cette qualité de l'eau et
j'ai été évidemment effaré par ce qu'on
nous a appris lors de ce colloque à
savoir qu'il y a de nouvelles entités
chimiques qui sont introduites
régulièrement et que nous avons dépassé
la sixième limite planétaire à ce sujet
là donc pour l'instant les constats qui
sont faits c'est qu'on a un certain
nombre de molécules qu'on doit
rechercher mais en fait on en a bien
bien plus et évidemment ce qu'on ne
cherche pas on ne va pas le trouver donc
on a des problèmes à venir colossaux à
gérer donc on est dans une espèce de
fuite en avant à ce sujet là sur
justement un manque de régulation sur
les nouvelles entités chimiques qu'on
utilise un nom comment faire
pour gérer cette concentration de
microplanque nous avons et enfin dernier
une dernière remarque que je voulais
faire puisque comme la plupart de mes
collègues je rencontre souvent je suis
toujours conseillère municipal dans ma
commune et nous avons une régime
municipale je voudrais appuyer sur le
fait que il nous faut faire confiance à
nos élus et notamment
commune qui sont en régie avec des des
adjoints qui gèrent qui connaissent les
réseaux mais malheureusement et j'ai
vraiment j'appuie là dessus ces
dernières années le manque de
subventions disponible pour justement
refaire les réseaux et beaucoup de
petites communes sont à la peine alors
qu'elles savent très bien ce qu'elle le
devrait et pourrait faire parce que elle
ne bénéficie pas de subventionnement
voilà je voulais juste te dire
merci j'ai donné la parole à
Jean-Baptiste
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs pour les réponses que vous
avez déjà apporté à mes collègues et qui
ont éclairé un petit peu ma lanterne je
voudrais poser deux questions
complémentaires une première sur
la réutilisation des eaux de STEP est-ce
que les normes que nous mettons en place
au niveau national
ne sont pas
prohibitives par rapport à celle qui
sont appliquées dans les autres pays
puisque vous dites que nous sommes
particulièrement en retard par rapport à
l'Espagne au Portugal
est-ce qu'on a besoin de la même qualité
d'eau quand on fait une arrosage un
arrosage par aspersion ou bien de façon
gravitaire quand on arrose des du
maraîchage ou qu'on arrose par
goutte-à-goutte des quais de vignes
voilà est-ce qu'il faut pas faire des
distinctions
c'est une première question et
secondes plutôt pour vous monsieur par
rapport
au barrage et aux productions
d'électricité et la régulation de l'eau
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas à
lier par exemple la production d'énergie
renouvelable telle qu'un parc
photovoltaïque qui produit de
l'électricité au moment où on n'a pas
nécessairement besoin de cette
électricité en maximum qui pourrait être
renvoyé au niveau des barrages pour
remonter de l'eau
et cette eau servirait à ce moment-là à
reproduire l'électricité au moment où on
en a besoin le matin et le soir
dans le Verdon avait la succession de
barrages ce serait particulièrement
efficace ça permettrait de continuer à
produire de l'électricité et de réserver
la quantité d'eau qui est nécessaire
pour le reste de la rivière de
l'utilisation de la rivière
merci la parole est à Martin
merci président et merci à nos
intervenants de ce matin qui nous
éclairent sur un sujet sur le sujet de
l'eau qui est un marqueur très important
aujourd'hui sur tout le volet changement
climatique
également qui soulève des vrais
questions dangereux que ce soit d'un
point de vue qualité ou d'un point de
vue quantité on l'a bien vu à travers
vos interventions et questions de mes
collègues
moi je souhaitais revenir plus
précisément sur l'intervention de
Monsieur Pellegrini dans vos propos
introductifs vous avez évoqué le besoin
selon vous de d'abonder le budget de
l'État sur le sur le sujet de l'eau je
ne sais pas si j'ai retenu le bon
chiffre si vous pouviez nous leur
rappeler et notamment je voulais savoir
ce que vous mettiez dedans pardon de de
le poser la question sous cette forme là
puisque on a évoqué le sujet du
recyclage de l'eau je vais pas revenir
là dessus donc toutes nos capacités vous
nous avez donné quelques chiffres par
rapport à un parangonnage européen bien
ce que certains États voisins font déjà
et récupèrent en ré-usage de ces taux là
je voulais savoir si vous vous comptiez
également dans le budget dans le montant
que vous avez partagé avec nous
également tout l'aspect de du patrimoine
autour de l'eau et je pense au
patrimoine enterré donc avec toutes les
fuites donc est-ce que cela suppose dans
votre esprit une prise en charge de
l'État sur un volet qui aujourd'hui
quand même est très prégnant également
pour nos collectivités et puis aussi sur
le dernier volet que les uns et les
autres vous avez partagé avec nous sur
la partie prévention donc d'une part si
vous pouviez nous redonner le montant
comment vous l'estimez-vous comment vous
êtes arrivés à ce chiffre là et selon
vous qu'est-ce qu'il comprend en réalité
pour qu'on arrive à avancer sur ces
sujets éminemment important je vous
remercie
la parole est à Jean-Claude Anglard
merci monsieur le Président d'abord je
voudrais à mon tour féliciter les
différents intervenants sur le sujet et
puis
remercier Monsieur de charger d'avoir
cité n'est-ce pas la validatrière et
rappeler ici le travail que nous avons
réalisé depuis 12 ans environ sur la
vallée de la Truyère et la vallée du Lot
notamment sur le fait que faire des
barrages c'est pas forcément gros mots
hein 2 que finalement territorialement
ça peut être un objet de développement
bien sûr bien sûr économique mais aussi
touristique et le travail qui a été fait
au travers de la route d'énergie n'est
ce pas avec une mise en résonance des
barrages qui sont faits donc dans le
Massif central avec les barrages qui
sont faits dans les Pyrénées en
résonance à Toulouse n'est-ce pas mon
permis à la métropole et aux petites
Toulousains de découvrir l'intérêt de
l'énergie hydroélectrique et de ce qui
va avec
ma question portée sur le renouvellement
des concessions hydroélectriques ça a
été déjà soulever et demander par
plusieurs collègues ma question elle
était par rapport au rapport que la les
magistrats de la Cour des comptes
viennent d'envoyer n'est-ce pas à Madame
le Premier ministre sur ce sujet en
disant un certain nombre de choses
premièrement que il y avait
que la France conduit ce sujet depuis 30
ans de façon chaotique c'est les mots
qui sont utilisés
que le calendrier des sciences donc
est important il rappelle dans ce
rapport qui a 340 installations entre
2003 2003 et 2080 qui vont être
renouvelés et donc
que 38 concessions à ce jour sont échues
et pas renouvelé et poursuivre la
exploitation sous le régime dérogatoire
des délais glissants donc il faut un
certain nombre de recommandations par
rapport à l'Europe et moi je voulais
savoir ce que vous pensez du référé de
ce la Cour des comptes donc du 6 février
qui alerte à la fois ce que je viens
d'indiquer sur le gouvernement sur les
conséquences de sa gestion chaotique de
l'ensemble du par hydroélectrique qui se
dégrade et qui ne peut pas jouer
pleinement son rôle dans la transition
énergétique et puis partagez-vous la vie
de la Cour des comptes qui dans ce même
référé indique qu'il est préférable que
d'opter pour la statue de la quasi régie
pour la gestion des concessions et du
Tour électrique plutôt que la mise en
concurrence voulue par Bruxelles merci
carole est à chevrolier
merci monsieur le Président merci aux
intervenants qui ont déjà abordé
beaucoup de sujets par rapport à la
gestion de l'eau face au changement
climatique moi je voudrais revenir sur
le sujet de la Table Ronde raréfaction
de la ressource en eau et qualité de
l'eau
souvent
exposé par les collègues moi j'aurais
insisté sur qualité de l'eau du robinet
parce que vous pouvez vous exprimer sur
la qualité de l'eau du robinet également
à notre point sur le prix de l'eau dans
un contexte de raréfaction de la
ressource en eau et en jeu ça a été un
petit peu abordé au travers du modèle
volumétrique est-ce que vous pouvez
développer sur ce qui pourrait être
proposé puisque pour être économe ça
peut aussi dépendre d'un facteur coût un
facteur prix et
quelle réaction par rapport à une
proposition de la création d'une Agence
nationale de l'eau qui aurait pour
mission de de Périco et un petit peu le
prix de l'eau afin d'éviter que l'eau ne
soit pas cher en ville et cher en à la
campagne
et ma deuxième question s'adresserait
directement à représentant d'EDF par
rapport à
cette question de l'hydroélectricité et
vous avez indiqué le potentiel alors
c'est pareil avec la baisse des débits
des cours d'eau et son impact bien sûr
sur vos activités mais en l'état vous
avez évoqué des études sur des nouvelles
installations est-ce que vous pouvez
aussi développer combien vous avez
d'études en cours combien de projets
seraient prêts à être éventuellement mis
dans le débat public merci
merci il n'y a plus de questions donc je
vous laisse le soin de répondre tout en
sachant que il faudrait qu'on détermine
à midi parce qu'on a un ordre du jour
complémentaire donc il faut que l'on
traite merci
je me lance rapidement sur le sur
l'hydroélectricité ce qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de beaucoup de questions
d'abord vous dire que en fait sur les
steps pour pour vous répondre madame la
sénatrice vous avez tout à fait raison
et vous avez très très bien décrit ce
que c'était que une station de transfert
d'énergie par pompage en fait on
s'aperçoit que nos stations de transfert
d'énergie pour leur pompage donc 5
gigawatts aujourd'hui en France sont
très très sollicités ça veut dire qu'en
fait ce besoin de flexibilité et
est avéré entre guillemets puisque nous
avons une usure de nos turbines de nos
stations de transfert d'énergie par
pompage qui sont très importantes donc
ça montre bien qu'il y a une
sollicitation très importante de ces de
ces de ces machines est-ce qu'ils vont
trop bien qu'il y a un besoin très
important de cette flexibilité et on
pense que cette flexibilité ce besoin de
flexibilité et donc de stockage donc
vous avez plusieurs parlé ici va être de
plus en plus important et ça me permet
de répondre aussi à votre à votre
question il y a beaucoup d'études en
interne et on est en train de mener un
projet justement de couplage entre ce
qu'on appelle les énergies renouvelables
variables et justement
l'hydroélectricité qui elle fait plutôt
le stockage la flexibilité et notamment
sur la chaîne Durance il y a pas mal
d'études sur ce sur ce volet là donc on
pourra éventuellement en parler en
aparté mais donc c'est vraiment des
sujets sur lesquels on innove énormément
pour faire en sorte que du
droélectricité qui est une vieille dame
puisse continuer à prospérer et à
continuer à apporter toutes ces tout ce
qu'elle peut apporter dans cette
transition énergétique dont je parlais
juste pour vous dire que on a de
nombreux projets mais comme je disais
tout ça c'est lié en fait à la
résolution de la mise en demeure de la
France sur le sujet hydroélectrique cité
donc là il faut qu'on arrive tous
collectivement à sortir de cette chose
là on a de nombreux projets le RTE donc
dans son futur énergétique le rapport
qu'il a sorti l'année dernière a bien
indiqué que il y avait un grand besoin
de flexibilité qui aurait un grand
besoin de flexibilité et à chiffrer déjà
d'ores et déjà à 3 gigawatts le besoin
donc de cette flexibilité et c'est vrai
que comme vous le disiez madame la
sénatrice ça serait dommage de passer à
côté de ses batteries liquides et normes
génial que la France a elle n'a pas
besoin d'importer aucun matériau on a
tout en fait et la chaîne en plus la
chaîne industrielle et essentiellement
française et européenne donc on a
quelque chose là sous la main qui est
qui est sensible et très important et
sur lequel on peut on peut aller et nous
sommes nous poussons avec les autres
hydroélectricien le chiffre de 1,5
gigawatts de STEP à horizon 2033 donc on
voit qu'on a des des projets nous dans
les dans les cartons qui me demandent
qu'être réalisé rapidement si tenter que
on puisse on puisse y aller et sur la
question sur la Cour des comptes je me
prononcerai pas la Cour des comptes
c'est a fait un référé auprès de la
première ministre c'est au gouvernement
donc de s'exprimer sur se référer il
n'empêche que je répondrai en biaisant
en disant que c'est sûr que toute
solution
sauf la mise en concurrence et pour EDF
forcément une une bonne solution
après il y a plusieurs possibilités et
donc au gouvernement en lien avec avec
vous les parlementaires de trouver la
solution qui qui le mérite
vous avez fait la transition à passer
directement la parole représente les
ministères
bien je vais répondre donc au sujet aux
questions qui ont été posées sur le
domaine agricole
sur l'aspect gestion quantitative
gestion qualitative de l'eau
il y a à l'évidence en lien dans la
réalité
il a la Délégation interministérielle
c'est une petite structure de 4
personnes nous avons une feuille de
route qui a été fixée par un décret qui
est la mise en oeuvre des conclusions du
varen des trois axes et 24 mesures c'est
vrai que ces conclusions sont
très essentiellement orienté sur la
gestion quantitative ça veut pas dire
que le qualitatif ne soit pas géré mais
il est géré dans d'autres structures
administratives que la délégation je
pense pour le ministère de l'Agriculture
à la direction générale de la
performance économique environnementale
des des exploitations mais il y a aussi
la direction de l'eau et de la
biodiversité
ma mission a été fixée pour trois ans
donc 2022 2025
à l'issue je dois rendre un rapport aux
deux ministres qui sont mes deux
autorités
mises à transition écologique ministre
de l'Agriculture
ça sera aux autorités gouvernementales
de décider le moment venu s'il y a lieu
de poursuivre cette mission et si il y a
lieu de l'étendre
des sujets autres que le cœur de sujets
qui est le programme du du varen
sur la qualité des eaux de
réutilisation
on a un point de vigilance à avoir mais
plus je dirais qui est qui est universel
qui concerne la France mais qui concerne
tous ceux qui utilisent cette technique
c'est de prévenir le passage
de résidus qui se trouverait dans l'eau
vers la production alimentaire qui qui
en résulte alors c'est vrai que c'est
une situation au cas par cas ce qui sort
d'une station d'épuration un endroit
n'est pas forcément ce qui en sort à un
autre mais en tout cas on doit rester
dans cette dans cette logique de de
prévention
il y a un élément aussi qu'il faut qu'il
faut introduire c'est pour ça que je
disais que c'est c'est un cas par cas ce
sont les situations où
les stations d'épuration contribuent
largement au débit desiages de certains
cours d'eau donc là c'est un c'est un
équilibre à avoir
il faut prendre en compte et c'est un
sujet qu'on a peut-être pas suffisamment
exploré actuellement le coût de
production du mètre cube
d'eau réutilisée évidemment plus on
augmente les exigences plus ça coûte est
élevé
et par exemple
en sortie d'industrie alimentaire
souvent le traitement se fait par la
technique dite osmose inverse c'est la
technique qu'on utilise entre autres
pour le dessalement de l'eau de mer et
qui est très coûteuse
en énergie donc c'est un des éléments de
de l'équilibre à prendre en compte en
tout cas le sujet réutilisation et
clairement
identifié nous sommes en train d'y
travailler l'objectif c'est bien entendu
d'accroître la part de cette ressource
complémentaire merci monsieur le
Président si Monsieur Pellegrini merci
de me redonner la parole sur la question
du financement de ce retard
d'investissement ou des investissements
complémentaires et évidemment centrale
je crois qu'il y a plusieurs réponses
qui peuvent être données tout d'abord
nos entreprises sont tout à fait prêtes
elles le font déjà avoir des modèles de
contractualisation avec des
collectivités territoriales qui nous
récompense au rendement et aux résultats
aujourd'hui dans bon nombre de nos
contrats en fait les investissements
sont à notre charge risque et péril et
on s'engage sur une amélioration de
rendement de réseau ce qui fait en fait
que les investissements sont choisis
étudiés et analyser et que les
entreprises peuvent s'engager très
largement sur une amélioration
significative du rendement de réseau il
y a d'autres types d'indicateurs
opérationnels qui peuvent aussi nous
permettre d'améliorer significativement
la qualité du service et qui peuvent
nous permettre d'être rémunérés donc
tout ça est très ouvert en tout cas il
n'y a pas besoin d'ajouter autre chose
il y a une palette de modèles de
contractualisation possible qui nous
permettent de nous exprimer faut
simplement qu'on réponde à la volonté de
nos clients dans un contexte où on
accumule des retards d'investissement le
plafond mordant capacité à écréter
au-delà d'un certain niveau et difficile
à comprendre
je peux pas vous en dire plus
sur la question du tarif je crois qu'il
y a plusieurs choses tout d'abord
aujourd'hui la tarification progressive
et pas toujours de mise la tarification
progressive c'est celle qui consiste à
ce que les gros consommateurs payent
davantage lorsque vous remplissez une
piscine d'eau l'été il peut paraître
raisonnable de payer son eau un peu plus
cher que les 30 premiers mètres cubes
qui servent aux besoins essentiels
encore une fois la tarification et
aujourd'hui une compétence des
collectivités territoriales et la
définition en fonction de leur volonté
pour l'éthique et leur sociologie tout
simplement que la tarification
l'ingénierie tarifaire est quelque chose
que nos entreprises s'affairent et qui
apporter demain pour savoir aujourd'hui
comment faire juste peut-être pour faire
le lien avec le prix de l'eau parce
qu'on n'a pas parlé le mètre cube d'eau
en France coûte 4 euros
en moyenne merci il est de 5,50 en
Allemagne
je compare à des systèmes où l'eau paylo
ce qui représente 0,8% du budget des
ménages ce qui veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas faire extrêmement attention au foyer
qui sont pas capables de faire face à ce
besoin essentiel il faut d'ailleurs les
accompagner nos entreprises ont proposé
de généraliser ce qu'on appelle le gecko
il y a d'autres dispositifs sociaux pour
accompagner en tout cas ce prix nous
semble raisonner et raisonnable
et enfin je crois qu'il y a d'autres
modèles aussi de financement je vous
parlais il y a quelques minutes du
projet
des rues européen sur l'assainissement
il propose d'intégrer le principe de
reps c'est à dire de pollueurs payeur
très largement utilisé dans le recyclage
des déchets qui pourraient là aussi
consister à capter des sources de
financement additionnels pour investir
et protéger cette ressource en nous en
tout cas une question que pose l'Europe
qui nous paraît extrêmement intéressante
sur la réutilisation des eaux usées
évidemment nous on propose de
systématiser dans les plantes
territoriaux de gestion de l'eau
l'analyse de tous les projets de
réutilisation il n'y a pas de sujet à
notre avis sur le littoral et évidemment
les steppes ou le rejet des stations
d'épuration participent à l'étage des
fleuves mais il s'agit pas de réutiliser
100%. il s'agit de rédiger une partie
pour les services industriels des
besoins des propres et pour les besoins
des collectivités territoriales et là où
la question est intéressante et où la
législation de mars 2002 ouvre la porte
à quelque chose d'intéressant c'est que
nous devons adapter la qualité d'eau aux
usages il est évidemment normal de
considérer que l'eau pour l'irrigation
doit être de l'eau potable ou proche en
revanche quand on nettoie la voirie
quand on arrose les espaces verts ou
pour des usages diverses et variés
industriels on peut très bien adapter la
qualité d'eau et quand on pense
adaptation de qualité d'eau on pense
évidemment à des modèles économiques qui
sont plus compétitifs donc tout ça doit
être évidemment légiférer au niveau
régional territorial de manière à
trouver les bons équilibres aujourd'hui
juste pour parler un peu des barrières
qu'on vous demande de nous aider à lever
il faut 10 ans pour mener à bien un
projet de réutilisation des eaux usées
aussi on a fait un certain nombre de
propositions notamment le guichet unique
au niveau du département pour faciliter
des démarches administratives des
périodes d'expérimentation qui soient
plus longues je pense que sur le plan
administratif on pourrait faire les
choses de manière un peu plus souple
rapide et flexible en tout cas ce que
nous proposons avec un observatoire
national qui pourrait s'exprimer sur la
qualité des eaux réutilisées de manière
à afficher une transparence complète
vis-à-vis de tous les usages donc c'est
des choses que nous avons proposé et qui
à mon avis sont tout à fait pertinentes
sur les retards d'investissement je vais
pas rentrer dans le détail mais on
pourra revenir vers vous les 15
milliards de retard que nous 15 à 17 en
fonction des estimations c'est la
filière française de l'eau c'est sur les
cinq prochaines années il y a deux gros
volets la sécurisation donc ça intègre
le renouvellement des distributs des
canalisations de distribution d'eau la
mise en conformité quand même de nos
usines d'assainissement qui ne sont pas
conformes l'interconnexion des systèmes
entre eux ça c'est pour la sécurisation
et sur la qualité santé environnement
c'est la qualité améliorée des eaux
rejetées dans le milieu c'est
l'amélioration de la qualité de
traitement des usines de production
d'eau potable contenu de ce qu'on
constate sur la ressource et c'est les
réseaux et l'amélioration de la qualité
des eaux pluviales rejetées vous savez
qu'il y a une directive qui nous impose
de ne pas rejeter sans les avoir traités
les eaux pluviales dans le milieu à
hauteur de 5% bon je crois que il y a
55% des des collectivités qui sont non
conformes donc ça englobe beaucoup de
choses pour essayer de mettre à niveau
encore une fois les services et les
réseaux d'eau et d'assainissement en
France sur la qualité d'eau du robinet
c'est évidemment une compétence qui nous
appartient pas elle appartient au
service de santé de l'État en tout cas
ce qui est certain c'est que l'eau en
France est conforme 24 heures sur 24 7
sur chandelles a une réglementation qui
s'inscrit parmi les meilleurs standards
mondiaux et voilà ce que je peux vous
dire sur le sujet
bien merci bien on va clore cette table
ronde merci merci aux intervenants on
voit on voit bien un travail à la
question à travers les réponses qu'il y
a un
immense chantier qui s'ouvre qui s'ouvre
devant nous parce que il faut à la fois
qu'on
réussisse à trouver des solutions pour
effectivement que que l'eau qui devient
un produit rare et bien ne devienne pas
un produit que l'on n'est plus et puis
il faut aussi que on est une autre
qualité et je pense que les traitements
les traitements sont très très
importants parce que même effectivement
comme vous l'avez dit si c'est pour
arroser ou nettoyer peut-être qu'on
n'est pas obligatoirement avoir besoin
de l'eau de vraiment de qualité mais on
peut pas rejeter dans des sous-sols
karstiques comme le disait notre
collègue Favreau tout à l'heure des eaux
qui ne sont pas de bonne qualité et qui
finissent dans nos rivières et qui
polluent nos rivières voilà donc il y a
un beau chantier qui est ouvert sur sur
le problème de l'eau et il y a des
questions que nous essaierons nous de
répondre à savoir s'il faut une nouvelle
loi s'il faut effectivement
répartir les compétences et voir qui
aura la compétence de ce sujet il faut
que c'est des sujets qui qui sont qui
sont fondamentaux qui faut vraiment
réfléchir et qui ne doivent pas être
tabou qui vont être difficiles à
résoudre mais qui ne doivent pas merci
pour votre participation